Nhưng mà các bạn phung nên theo kiểu không theo kiểu là dùng
dùng cứu thì kèng các bạn hiểu bà chất là xe không
Mới tất bảo là gì đây
Tốc gộ lúc dùng nên cũng mừng nước
Bằng bò nhiều khi mừng lúc dùng để đồ xong bà
Tất cả khi mà hát còn bà
thì thời gian bò tèo mà nhiều lọc
Môn tính tốc lúc dùng nên là dùng nên là dùng nên là dùng nên là dùng nên là dùng tính thông bà
Cái biến này ở biến thời gian
Hát phải tệ thông mà mò nhiều
Vậy để mà tính hát tệ thì không bước dân càng tìm bú bói rả nhớ tìm
Bà chem bù tìm theo tệ thích
Thế thích không đổi
Thì sau tìm cũng thì kèng xe có về mà hãy tìm
Mà đứng nhé
Càng cú gó về tìm nhé hát
Nhưng bà cũng nãy dụi về kèm tìm theo tệ
Đi nó thơ hát